now i want to shift to another late
night host who i've really been working
on so you already know who i'm talking
about i want to talk about bill maher
for just a second because bill maher's
show on friday he did it again every
time i i give this guy credit and by the
way producers of bill maher show i know
you're watching as always um
i give this guy credit when he gets it
right on wokism and crt and everything
he doesn't vote the right way okay i'm
not sure what makes him a liberal in a
modern sense anymore
but here he is just going right back
into the republicans are racists okay
well um we have the first black woman
let's go back for some of the people who
don't remember this also the first black
we ever had we've only had two thurgood
marshall 1967. when he died uh
it was george bush the first was
president
and so they accepted the idea that there
was now a black seat on the court and
that's how we got clarence thomas now i
thought it was
not exactly cricket to give the black
seat to someone who didn't represent the
majority of black thinking in america
but here's the difference at least they
accepted george bush did the idea of we
at least one black seat on the court
right i think today's republicans would
not do that i think they would be
thrilled to have no black seats on the
court okay a lot of them okay so judging
judging by
because by the way they treated this
nominee right which one's exactly which
was racist top to bottom
all right i i don't know who that loser
is at the end there was nothing racist
in the hearings to catanji brown jackson
there was absolutely nothing racist
asking someone if they know what a woman
is is not racist she's going to be
confirmed either way no one said oh
you're black you can't you can't be a
judge that would be racist okay so that
guy's just a clown forget that as for
bill maher i don't know what to do with
this guy anymore like this is all you
got it's all you got left is my
political opponents are racist it's very
unfortunate right it's unfortunate that
someone could get so far in their
thinking really understand
the right side of things in so many ways
critical race theory and wokism and even
the covid stuff and all that you sure
you were wrong and wrong and wrong for
years but then you come around okay
better late than never fine and we want
to we want to welcome people to the same
side with open arms but still the
implication
that
the supreme court justice nominee that
the hearings had anything to do with
racism the idea that there should be a
black seat in 2022 america that there
should be a black do we have a um an
italian-american seat is there is there
a seat for tony soprano is there a seat
for asian americans is there a seat for
native americans is there a seat for
pansexual two-spirit americans is there
a seat for jewish americans is there a
seat for muslim americans this is
complete
neo-racist nonsense so you rail against
woke-ism you rail against equity but you
want equity apparently or you realize
that you're just getting too damn close
to the truth and i think that's probably
what it is
you're too damn close to what the truth
is so at the end it's uh but the
republicans still are all racist you
think ted cruz's questioning
of katanji brown jackson was racist and
also he said something that was really
really awful there that um the majority
of black thinking that these meaning
clarence thomas doesn't represent the
majority of black thinking i did not
know
that um black people think a certain way
i thought the black people are
individual people who could think all
sorts of different ways i don't know if
you were to poll all black people that
they would agree on something and just
because a majority
think something that doesn't mean it's
right have you ever heard of the term
the tyranny of the majority so the
majority of black thinking meaning we
should hold a seat for black people
and then we should install people who
just think the way we sort of think that
the majority of black people think and
that would be the not racist thing to do
do you understand why this is so [ __ ]
backwards
bill i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do i think i'm on your
podcast in a couple weeks and i look
forward to talking about it so this is
not an attack on you but what i don't
get it man
i don't get it at this point
and that other guy i mean just just an
epic clown all they have is racism all
they have is racism and we have to
realize that it doesn't work you don't
want the majority of the tyranny that's
the point i go into that in my book by
the way
in case you're interested